مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون نواهد
احييكم واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه على
العربيه
عشيه يوم النصر موسكو تحيي نصرا قديما
وعينها على اوكرانيا والنيتو يتاهب
مع تجدد الاشتباكات وسط الخرطوم البرهان
يخشى ان تنتقل شراره الحرب الى الولايات
الاخرى
مصادر استخباراتيه اردنيه تؤكد قتل
المطلوب الاول بتهريب المخدرات
واستهدافها معمل للكبتاجون في درعا
واللاجئون السوريون في اجنده الانتخابات
التركيه شبح الترحيل يحوم مع اقتراب يوم
الاقتراع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في يوم نصرها عينا روسيا
منشغلتان واحده بالتحضير واخرى على
اوكرانيا حيث انشغلت روسيا بوضع لمسات
الاخيره استعدادا للاحتفال بواحده من اهم
مناسباتها السنويه ورغم الخطوات العسكريه
التي اتخذتها السلطات فان المخاوف بشان
الامن الداخلي بعد سلسله ضربات جويه اربكت
الوضع وادت الى الغاء احتفالات في بعض
المدن
هكذا يبدو مدخل الساحه الحمراء عشيه
احتفال روسيا بالنسخه الثامنه والسبعين
لعيد النصر في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
تشديد امني وتواجد لعشارات العناصر
والاليات في كل مكان داخل مركز العاصمه
صراع روسيا مع الغرب القى بظلاله على واقع
العاصمه موسكو ملف المسيرات الضاربه خاصه
تلك التي حلقت فوق مبنى الكرملين حول
المكان الى سكنتين وفرض واقعه من القلق
لدى القائمين والشارع الروسي
من يخاف من الذئب يجب ان لا يدخل الغابه
ولا مهرب من المصير فالابتعاد عن مثل هذه
الاماكن خوفا من المسيرات غير مجددا فهناك
سيارات في الشوارع وسكوترات قد تودي بحياه
الانسان نستمتع بوقتنا من
دون استعداد تستمر منذ ايام اغلاق للشوارع
المجاوره لمبنى لفتح المجال امام الاليات
المشاركه في العرض العسكري وضع اعتده
المواطن الروسي من قبل لكن ليس بهذه الحده
لا توجد انظمه دفاع جوي تحمي بشكل كامل
القوات هنا في مهمه لحفظ الامن والوضع من
ايه اخطار
العاشره صباحا من التاسع من مايو هو موعد
الاحتفال بعيد النصر هذا المكان سيكون
حكرا على حاملي بطاقات الحضور هذه لكن مع
التدقيق والفحص الشديدين عبد الجواد
الروشت العربيه
لهذا الحدث اهميه اخرى خصوصا ان خبراء كان
نرجح ان تشن اوكرانيا الهجوم المضاد في
اليوم ذاته وذلك لارباك الاحتفالات
بالمقابل اعلن الرئيس الاوكرانيس كان
اوكرانيا ستتخلى عن احياء ذكرى الانتصار
على المانيا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه في
التاسع من مايو وفقا للتقليد السوفيتي
والروسى واضاف انه سيقدم الى البرلمان
مشروع قانون يعلن الثامن من مايو يوم
الذكرى والنصر على النازيه حسب تعبيره
لن نسمح بالاستيلاء على الانتصار المشتركي
لشعوب التحالف المناهض الهتلر ولن نسمح
باكاذيب كان النصر كان يمكن ان يتم دون
مشاركه اي دوله او شعب دمرنا الشر معا مثل
ما نواجه الان شرا مشابها معا
هذا رفع حلف الناتو من جاهزيه وحداته
الجويه ردا على ما وصفه بالسلوك الخطير
الذي ينتهجه الجيش الروسي بالقرب من حدود
الحلف واكد مسؤول في الناتو لوكاله رويترز
ان مقاتله روسيه قامت بمناوره خطيره كادت
تتسبب بفقدان السيطره على طائره بولنديه
فوق البحر الاسود غير بعيد عن الحدود
الرومانيه وهو ما استدعى رفع الناتو
لمستوى الجاهزيه على حدوده الشرقيه
منك ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
حذيفه اهلا بك معنا ما هي ابرز المخاوف
لدى الاوكرانيين كشعب وايضا لدى الحكومه
الاوكرانيه بيوم النصر في روسيا خاصه بعد
هذا التصعيد الاخير في الايام الماضيه
والدرون التي تم اسقاطها فوق الكريم
مساء الخير ميسون في الحقيقه هنالك فعليا
تصعيد كبير في الاسبوع او الاسبوع ونصف
الاخير من قبل الاتحاد الروسي في الهجمات
الموجهه نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه لا سيما
في اليومين الماضيين وكذلك في الليله
الماضيه 35 طائره مسيره استهدفت العاصمه
كييف و16 صاروخا استهدفت الاراضي
الاوكرانيه في عدد من المدن هذه الليله
يعني يعتقد او من المرجح ان تنام كيف
بعينين مفتوحتين وتراقب السماء جيدا هنالك
قلق كبير جدا من المواطنين الاوكرانيين
مما يمكن ان يحدث في هذه الليله يتوقع
المواطنون ان يكون هنالك هجوم واسع على
النطاق من قبل الاتحاد السوفيتي بالصواريخ
الباليستيه وكذلك الطائرات المسيره خاصه
في العاصمه كييف اليوم تحدثت الى عدد من
المواطنين جميعهم قلقون يقولون انهم
سيراقبون جيدا وقد يعني لا ينامون حتى
البعض منهم يقول انهم قد يذهبون الى
مراقبه
الليل اذا ما كان سيكون هنالك هجوم تعلمين
ان الهجمات في الغالب يتضرر منها او يعني
تحدث الوفيات عندما يكون المواطنين نائمين
في بيوتهم وتحدث الانفجارات في شقاقهم
وتنهار المنازل لذلك
سيتبعون بعض الاجراءات لمراقبه الوضع في
هذه الليله وهنالك قلق كبير عن الصعيد
الشعبي اما على الصعيد الرسمي
فالمسؤولين يعني ايضا رجعوا ان يكون هنالك
عمليه هجوم واسعه النطاق خاصه الدفاع
الجوي الاوكراني رجح ان يكون هنالك ضربه
من قبل الاتحاد الروسي اليوم نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني قالت قد يكون هنالك هجوم
وقد لا يكون هنالك هجوم نحن نعلم ان روسيا
يعني
تحاول في المناسبات الخاصه ان ترسل
الهدايا الى اكيييث وطبعا لابد هنا ان
نذكر ان في العام الماضي مع للرغم من ان
الجميع توقع ضربه قويه وكبيره من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي الا ان الليله مضت بهدوء
شديد في العام الماضي وكذلك نهار
الاحتفالات ايضا مضى بهدوء ولم يكن هنالك
اي ضربات من قبل الاتحاد الروسي لا احد
يعلم طبعا اذا كانت ستوجه روسيا ضربات نحو
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ام لا ولكن الجميع قلق
وهنالك مخايف كبيره دعنا نذهب الان الى
زميلنا في موسكو م العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا يوم النصر
سيحل غدا ابرز الاستعدادات خاصه كما ذكرنا
مع حذيفه بعد هذا التصعيد الكبير الذي حصل
في الايام الماضيه
مساء الخير ميسون لك ولحذيفه نعم بالفعل
يعني تجديد امني كبير وتواجد لعشرات
الفرق الخاصه والاليات العسكريه في مركز
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو نحن ابتعدنا قليلا
ميسون عن مركز المدينه لنتمكن من استخدام
المعدات يعني حتى ان الاجهزه الامنيه تقوم
بالتشويش على عمل جميع يعني اجهزه
البلوتوث وحتى الجي بي اس الخرائط لا يعمل
بشكل صحيح بالمدينه كلها خطوات امنيه يعني
تسعى موسكو من خلاله الى ضبط الوضع وعدم
تمكن المسيرات من الطيران او الوصول الى
نقاط حساسه طبعا ميسون من المنتظر في
العاشره صباحا من يوم الغد هو بدا
الاحتفال الكبير بعيد النصر في صحه
الحمراء الرئيس الروسي
وعدد من رؤساء طبعا الدول التي كانت تدخل
ضمن قائمه الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
بالاضافه الى عدد الشخصيات متوقع طبعا
وزير الدفاع ووزير الخارجيه بالاضافه
الحلفاء كالرئيس البيلاروسيا الكسندر على
العموم ميسون يعني العرض يوم الغد سيشهد
عرض عسكري كبير كما هو متوقع يعني كثير من
التحليلات السياسيه في البلاد راحت تتحدث
عن الناموسكو قد تخرج يوم غد باليه عسكريه
محدثه قد تظهر فيها الساحه الحمراء
بالاضافه الى ان سماء المدينه طبعا
ستملؤها المقاتلات والطائرات
والمسيرات بالاضافه الى المروحيات واجهزه
عمل الدفاع الجوي لذلك طبعا هو يوم كبير
وشق تحدثنا اليوم كنا في وسط الساحه
الحمراء تحدثنا مع المواطنين الروس
المتواجدين في تلك المنطقه معظمهم يتحدث
عن عدم خوفهم من الحضور بالرغم من
المسيرات التي ضربت الكريم لكنهم يلاحظون
بشكل كبير التشديد الامني الذي تقوم به
موسكو خلال هذه الفتره المواطن الروسي
معتاد على هذا الشيء في شهر مايو من كل
عام يعني تحدث ذات
التفقيقات الامنيه بما يخص هذا الموضوع
الا انه في هذه السنه هو مشدد بشكل كبير
يعني خاصه مع قضيه المسيرات التي اصبحت
تلعب دور محوري كبير في الصراع بين موسكو
طبعا عبد الجواد سنتابع معكم غدا ايضا هذا
اليوم طويل وهذه الاحتفالات اشكرك من
موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد كما
اشكر زميلنا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل كنت
معي من كازا
[موسيقى]
على مدار ال 14 شهرا الماضيه لاعبه
المسيرات دورا كبيرا في المواجهات
الميدانيه بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
وشهدت صعيدا هائلا في استغلالها حيث حققت
طائرات بيرقدار تركيا الصنع النتائج نوعيه
فتصدي للدبابات الروسيه واحبط التقدمها
على اكثر من محور كما ادت الى انسحابها
ولا سيما في الجبهه الشماليه الشرقيه وفي
خرسون لكنه هدوء الجبهات واقتصارها على
المواجهات في بخمت بالاضافه الى استهداف
البنى التحتيه العسكريه
والاقتصاديه في الداخل قد اعطى للمسيرات
الدوره الاكبر في تشكيل الذراع العسكريه
الافعى والاقل تكلفه للحفاظ على استدامه
الحرب فلعقود من الزمن كانت الطائرات
المسيره جزءا من المخزون العسكري لمختلف
الدول حيث تطورت خلال السنوات الاخيره من
اداء مهام التجسس الى المهام الهجوميه
[موسيقى]
في القاره السمراء خطوه تقابل بخطوه وصراع
النفوذ بين واشنطن وروسيا لم يحط رحاله
بعد وفق صحيفه بوليتيكو فما توسيع مجموعه
فاجن الروسيه وجودها في البلدان الافريقيه
تستخدم اداره الامريكيه استراتيجيه وصفتها
الصحيفه بالسمينه ما هي هذه الاستراتيجيه
هي تقتصر على مشاركه المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه الحساسه مع حلفائها في
افريقيا في محاوله لثني الدول عن عقد
شركات مع فاجنر الصحيفه ايضا لفتت ان هذا
التكتيك يستخدم حاليا ضمن حمله اوسع لمنع
موسكو من الحصول على موطئ قدم اقتصادي
وعسكري في دول افريقيه بينها من عمل سابقا
مع واشنطن وفقا لمقابلات مع اربعه مسؤولين
امريكيين على درايه بهذا الامر
صراع النفوذ في منطقه الساحل الافريقي
متوسط بين واشنطن وموسكو التي تعمل على
توسيع وجودها كقوه لا يمكن احتوائها في
القاره السمراء جهود كبيره يتم بذلها من
طرف مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه في المنطقه
هدفها التمدد في البلدان الافريقيه
لمنافسه الغرب تحديدا واشنطن التي تسعى هي
الاخرى لضرب شبكات فاجنر العسكريه
ومصالحها الاقتصاديه فتحركات فاجنر باتت
مصدر قلق كبير بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن الذي
كشف عن استراتيجيه جديده تناولها تقرير
صادر عن صحيفه بوليتيكو يسعى من خلالها
لكبح المساعي الروسيه في المنطقه من خلال
تبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه
الحساسه المتعلقه بفاجنر مع الحلفاء في
افريقيا
واقناعهم بتجنب عقد شركات مع هذه المجموعه
بحسب الصحيفه هذا التكتيك يخدم الوظيفه
المزدوجه المتمثله في تنبيه الحلفاء
بالتهديدات واخطار الخصوم بان واشنطن على
درايه بتحركاتهم حيث تم الكشف عن معلومات
استخباراتيه تتعلق بخطه
لاغتيال رئيس تشاد ومحاولتها الوصول الى
مواقع استخراج الموارد الطبيعيه والسيطره
عليها وغير بعيد عن ذلك عرضت واشنطن على
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى تدريب جيشها مقابل
طرد قوات فاغنر وفق مقال لصحيفه لوماندا
الفرنسيه وذلك بعد ان تزايد النفوذ الروسي
في كل من السودان وليبيا وزيمبابوي
وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد والنيجر وموزمبيق
وجمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه شبكه فاجنر
التي تسعى لابرام اتفاقيات دفاعيه وامنيه
من بوابه تقديم الدعم لدول افريقيا
تخفي وراء تحركاتها اطمع موسكو التي ترغب
في جعل روسيا احد المشاركين الاقوياء في
القاره
[موسيقى]
باعاده مواطنيها قصرا من السودان بعد ان
فروا من الخرطوم نحو منطقه حدوديه هربا من
القتال وفقا لصحيفه الجاردن وبحسب ناشط
حقوقي اريتري مقيم بالخرطوم تحدث للصحيفه
البريطانيه فان اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
وخمسمائه تم ترحيلهم لبلادهم قصرا وجاء
ترحيل هؤلاء اللاجئين من كسلا بالسودان
الى تسني بئريتريا حيث ان المسافه بين
المدينتين لا تتجاوز التسعين كيلو مترا
[موسيقى]
في السودان تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق عده
بالخرطوم حيث ارتفعت اعمده الدخان في
العاصمه في وقت يجتمع ممثلون عن الجيش
والدعم في جده لبحث وقف اطلاق النار وفتح
ممرات انسانيه وسبل لانهاء الاسماء وكان
مراسل العربيه افدى باشتباكات جرت صباح
اليوم في ام درمان والخرطوم او سماع اصوات
مضادات في وقت حلقت فيه الطائرات بسماء
العاصمه
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات صحفيه قال مبعوث رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
السفير دفع الله الحاج ان المفاوضات التي
تجري في جده لا تلغي دور مبادره الايجاد
الافريقيه في الوساطه مشيرا الى انهم
يفضلون الحلول السلميه
من دعاه الحرب والحرب لا يقبلها اي شخص
نحن
نفضل
الحلول السلميه
ونفضل
وتهمنا سلامه وامن مواطنين لكن
الحكومه هي التي اجبرت على ذلك متى ما
وضعوا السلاح متى ما وضعوا سلاح سوف
يتم
العفو عنهم وادماجهم ولكن حتى الان هم
الذين يهاجمون ويحملون سلاح ضد القوات
المسلحه السوداني من جانبه كشفا وزير
الخارجيه جنوب السودان وان المبعوث الخاص
للامين العام للامم المتحده في السودان
طلب من الرئيس الباكار خلال اتصال هاتفيا
بدعوه الجنرال للقدوم الى جوبا لعقد
لقاءات مباشره
تلقى الرئيسي
صباح اليوم اتصالا هاتفيا من المبعوث
الخاص للامين العامي للامم المتحده في
السودان من بورسودان تحدث فيه عن الاوضاع
في السودان وطلب من الرئيس كير بدعوه
القاده السودانيين الى جوبا حيث تحدث كير
عن صعوبه التنقل ولكنه رحب بالبرهان
وحميتي فيجو
ولدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه بقرار من
الحكومه السوريه الفصائل الايرانيه تزيل
راياتها والعلم الايراني من مواقع لها في
سوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه بعد
ساعات على مقتل مهرب مخدرات بارز جنوبي
سوريا مصادر استخباراتيه اردنيه
ودبلوماسيه غربيه كشفت ان الاردن نفذ
غارتين على موقعين المخدرات جنوبي سوريا
حيث استهدفت الغاره الاولى معملا
للكبتاجون في درعا اما الثانيه قتلت
المطلوبه الاول بتهريب المخدرات عند
الاردن مرعي بمنزله شرقي السويداء والذي
نقلت رويترز انه على علاقه وثيقه بميليشيا
حزب الله بدوره اوضح وزير الخارجيه امام
الصفدي انه عندما يتخذ الاردن اي خطوه
تتعلق بتهديد امنه سيعلن عنها في الوقت
المناسب مؤكدا ان بلاده اتفقت مع سوريا
على تشكيل فريق امنيا سياسي لمواجهه خطر
المخدرات
عندما نتخذ اي خطوه
لحمايه امننا الوطني ومواجهتي اي تهديد له
سنعلنها في وقتها المناسب بالنسبه لقضيه
المخدرات كما اكدنا سابقا هو هي تهديد
كبير للمملكه وللمنطقه وللعالم ايضا في
ضوء تصاعد عمليات تهريب المخدرات تذكرين
اننا في اجتماع عمان اشرنا الى هذا
اتفقنا مع اخواتنا في الحكومه السوريه
باننا سنشكل فريقا سياسيا
امنيا مشتركا لمواجهه هذا الخطر
الانتهاء منه بشكل كامل مستمرون في العمل
من اجل انشاء تلك اللجنه وساتصل بمعالي
وزير الخارجيه السوريه قريبا لنبحث كيف
نترجم هذا الاتفاق الى اليه عمل واضحه
تساعدنا على مواجهه هذا الخطر وتحدوا منه
وعلى اتصال وقنواتنا مفتوحه مع الحكومه
السوريه
بعمان ينضم اليها لواء ركن محمد محمود
الثلجي المحلل العسكري والاستراتيجيه حضرت
لواء اهلا بكم معنا هل يمكن اعتبار بان
قواعد الاشتباكات لدى الاردن تغيرت ماذا
لدينا من تفاصيل عن هذه الغاره ومقتل هذا
يعني المطلوب الاول الذي يروج المخدرات
مساء الخير لك سيدتي وللاخوه المشاهدين
بالطبع وفكر الراي بان يعني ما ذكرتي بانه
صحيح مئه بالمئه اذا كانت اذا كانت القوات
المسلحه الاردنيه هي من قامت بهذه العمليه
بالرغم من ان الجانب الاردني لا زال يلتزم
الصمت ولم يدري باي تصريحات تشير يعني
بانه هو من قام بهذه العمليه الا ان يعني
من الاحتمالات الوارده والتي لا يمكن نفها
بانه يمكن ان يكون الجانب الاردني هو من
نفذ هذه العمليه واذا كان كذلك فان هذا
بالطبع ينطوي على تغييرات خطيره في في
قواعد الاشتباك وهو يحمل عده وهذه العمليه
بالمناسبه تحمل عده رسائل ثلاثه رسائل
مهمه في نظري بغض النظر عن من قام بهذه
العمليه وهذه الرسائل في في مجملها اي
رساله سياسيه في المقام الاول بان يعني
الاطراف المتورطه يجب ان لا تخطئ في تصميم
عمان على المضي قدما في مواجهه ومكافحه
هذه الافه وهذه الظاهره الخطيره
العاصمه عمان لن تصمت طويلا ولن تقف
محايده يعني ما يجري ومن اصرار على امطار
حدودها بكميات ضخمه وهائله
عن تدخل عسكري بحال لم يتم ضبط الحدود هل
يمكن اعتبار هذا الذي حصل اليوم واذا كانت
الاردن قامت به التدخل عسكري ام لا
نعم سيدتي هو هذا يعني هذه العمليه جاءت
فقط بعد 48 ساعه من من تصريح وزير
الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي في ان اذا
لم تقم الجهات السوريه بكبح جماح تجار
المخدرات ومصانع المخدرات فان الاردن
سيتخذ ما يلزم من الاجراءات للتدخل ولو
تطلب ذلك التوغل داخل الاراضي السوريه
وهذا التصريح كان علني وعلى وسائل يعني
اعلام متعدده عبر قنوات على هذه
اللواء اعذرني التوقيت التوقيت جاء بعد
يوم واحد من عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه هل يمكن اعتبار بانه كان هناك
تنسيق بين الجانب الاردني والجانب السوري
حتى قاموا بهذه الغاره خاصه بانه الجانب
السوري ايضا حتى الان يلتزم الصمت لم
يتحدث عن اي اعتداء على اراضيه
سيدتي اتفق معك تماما في الوقت الذي كان
وزراء الخارجيه العرب يجتمعون
للتصويت على عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي
كانت القوات المسلحه الاردنيه في الواجهه
الشماليه او الواجهه الشرقيه تقاوم وتكافح
يعني تفشل عمليات تهريب مخدرات ضخمه جدا
بملايين بملايين الحبات من الكبتاجون
والمخدرات والانواع الاخرى تصوري بان
الاردن يقود الجهد العربي وجهود اردنيه
دبلوماسيه مكثفه في هذا السبيل بينما
قواته على الجانب الاخر تقاوم وتكافئ
عمليات التسلل والتهريب عبر الحدود والتي
كانت يعني خطره جدا وكانت ملايين ملايين
الحبات من الكبتاج ونوال المخدرات في
طريقها الى الاردن لولا لولا افشاله هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى اذا افترضنا جدلا
بان القوات المسلحه الاردنيه والسلاح الجو
الاردني هو من قام بهذه العمليه فان الصمت
الروسي واسع عفوا الصمت السوري والصمت
الاردني هو يدل على انه هنالك اتفاق ضمني
فيما بين الطرفين لعدم الافصاح عن لعدم
الادلاء باي تصريحات اعلاميه بهذا الشان
وهذا ربما ياتي من باب ان الدبلوماسيه
الاردنيه تريد حفظ ماء وجه دمشق في هذا في
هذا المجال كون هذا التدخل داخل الاراضي
السوريه وبالتالي لا تريد الدوله الاردنيه
قالت لا باي تصريحات قد تكون مضره
دبلوماسيا بالسياده السوريه على على
اراضيها الا ان يعني بالتاكيد لن تقدم
القوات المسلحه الاردنيه وسلاحها الجوي
على الدخول الى نادي السوريه بدون ان يكون
اولئك ربما اشاره او يعني ضوء اخضر بانه
لا عليكم يعني تستطيعون معالجه هذا الموقف
بالوسائل التي ترونها مناسبه وربما كان
هنالك اتفاق على هذه الوسائل هذا من ناحيه
من ناحيه اخرى انا اتصور سيدتي بان الدوله
السوريه احجمت عن القيام بهذا الفعل والذي
كان الجانب الاردني يامل ان تقوم الدوله
السوريه بهذا بهذا الفعل وان تمارس
سيادتها على الاراضي السوريه وان تكون هي
الطرف الاخر على الحدود ولكن اذا نظرنا
الى الارتباطات الاقليميه
والى الدور الذي لعبته يعني هذه
الميليشيات في حفظ النظام السوري وكيف
ساعدت النظام السوري على الثبات وعلى
البقاء فان اليد السوريه لم تنتد وهذا كان
بالتاكيد شكرا لك ما احجمت عنه القياده
السوريه عن فعله وبالتالي تركت الامر
منوطا الى القوات الاردنيه اشكرك من عمان
اللواء الركن محمد محمود الثلجي المحل
العسكري والاستراتيجيه على المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى كل التطورات الحاصله
في السودان ينضم الينا من الخرطوم الان
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا
هل يمكن ان تعطينا صوره عن ابرز التطورات
اليوم واين تركزت هذه الاشتباكات
اهلا بك واهلا بالمشاه الكرام نعم كانت
هنالك تطورات ربما احداث كثيره جدا منذ
صباح اليوم تمركزت هذه الاشتباكات وتطورات
في محيط القصر الرئاسي ومدينه بحري ايضا
كذلك من خلال معسكر المظلات او الدائره
الطبيه لقوات الدعم السريع وامتدت ايضا
الى وسط العاصمه الخرطوم في السوق العربي
وعدد من الشوارع الطرفيه امتدت هذه
الاشتباكات ربما طوال النهار وحتى حلول
الظلام الان نتمتع بهدوء نسبي وحذر من
خلال ما يجري وما جرى طوال اليوم قبل
لحظات من الان هنالك تطورات جديده فيما
يخص البيانات العسكريه القوات المسلحه
السودانيه خرجت ببيان قبل نصف ساعه من
الان تحدثت فيها حول عديد من النقاط ربما
تشير لان الموقف العمليات مستقر في عدد
كبير من الولايات باستثناء ولايه الخرطوم
ومناطق معينه وهذا
دوما في بيان الجيش يشير ان ولايه الخرطوم
لم تعد مستقره في عدد من المناطق فيها
التي تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم السريع والتي
تجري فيها اشتباكات البيان فيه اشاره
جديده لان الجيش ملتزم به قواعد الاشتباك
والانسان باعتبار انه لا يقصف الاحياء ولا
المناطق التي تتواجد فيها المدنيين وهذا
هو حديث الجيش قبل قليل قوات الدعم السريع
ايضا كذلك ردت من خلال بيان نشر قبل
لحظاتنا الان تحدث هذا البيان في عده نقاط
ابرز هذه النقاط ايضا هي نقطه تحدثت فيها
قوه الدعم السريع من خلال البيان بانهم
سوف يسلمون جميع الاسرى من القوات المسلحه
والذين سوف يسلمون انفسهم لقوات الدعم
السريع الى اسرهم فورا او ذلك التزاما
بمبدا بالمبدا الانساني مع الجهاد ذات
الصله المتخصصه بالعمل الانساني وتطوع في
البلاد ربما هنا اشاره الى المنظمات
الدوليه قد تدخل الى هذه النقطه هذا كله
ياتي قبل جلسه الامم المتحده والاحاطه
التي سوف يقدمها السيد فولكر بيتس مبعوثه
الامم المتحده الى السودان التي من المقرر
ان تكون غدا الثلاثاء باعتبارها الجلسه
مغلقه واحاطه عن الوضع الانساني وهذا ايضا
ياتي جله بالتزامن مع عمليات المفاوضات
التي تجري في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
بقرارنا من الحكومه السوريه الفصائل
الايرانيه بدات بانزال العلم الايراني
وراياتها عن مواقع كثيره تابعه لها داخل
الاراضي السوريه وفق المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان حيث جرى انزال العلم الايراني
والرايات وفقا لما رصده نشطاء والمرصد
السوري من مواقع في مدينه دير الزور
ومدينتي الميادين والبكمال بريف دير الزور
الشرقي بالاضافه لمدينه تدمر ومحيطها بريف
حمص الشرقي واستبدلت الرايات بالعالم
السوري المعترف به دوليا واكد المرصد
السوري ان ازاله الاعلام والرايات لم
يصاحبها انسحاب وعناصر تلك الفصائل
[موسيقى]
في تركيا ومع اقتراب الانتخابات وبلغه
الارقام مشاهدينا يبلغ العدد الاجمالي
للناخبين 64 مليونا
داخل تركيا وخارجها يدلون باصواتهم للدقه
اكثر داخل تركيا يبلغ عدد الناخبين 60
مليونا
و697,843 مواطنا موزعين على 81 ولايه اي
اكثر من 94 من اجمالي من يحق لهم التصويت
اما الناخبون المقيمون خارج تركيا فيمثلون
حوالي خمسه من اجمالي ناخبين ويبلغ عددهم
ثلاثه ملايين و416 الفا وثمانيه وتسعين
مواطنا لكن السؤال لمن يصوت الناخبون
الجدد البالغ عددهم نحو خمسه ملايين ناخب
تكتسب هذه الكتله خصوصيه بالانتخابات
القادمه لانها تمثل الجيل الجديد الذي
يصوت للمره الاولى ولم يعرف كيف كانت
تركيا قبل وصول حزب العداله والتنميه
للسلطه لاول مره عام 2002 وككل موسم
انتخابي تستحوذ اسطنبول على الاهتمام
الاكبر ليس فقط لوزنها الانتخابيه الاكبر
داخل تركيا بل لانها كانت بوابه وصول
اردوغان للسلطه حينما تولى رئاسه بلديتها
عام 1994
استخدمت المعارضه للاجئين السوريين كورقه
ضغط ضد الحكومه من خلال نشرها الخطاب
المعادي وتحميلهم مسؤوليه كل شيء المعارضه
ركزت خطابها بالكامل على اعاده السوريين
بالكامل الى بلادهم فيما تعهد اردوغان
باعادتهم الى مناطق امنه ستقيمها تركيا في
الجانب الاخر من الحدود
عند تصوير اي تقرير عن اللاجئين السوريين
في اسطنبول يكون حي الفاتح وجهتنا
الرئيسيه لماذا هذا الحي على وجه التحديد
لان عشرات بل مئات المحال والمطاعم
والشركات السوريه اختار اصحابها الانطلاق
من هذا الحي التاريخي الذي يعتبر الاكثر
استقطابا للاجئين
اذا القسم الاكبر من النشاط التجاري
والاقتصادي للاجئين السوريين يتركز في حي
الفاتح وهذا يعني بالضروره عماله سوريه
كبيره تعمل هنا كعماد الذي يعمل في احد
محل الحلويات وعماد كغيره من اللاجئين
يخشى نتائج الانتخابات القادمه يعني هو
بس الفكره انه ما نجح الرئيس اردوغان يعني
في
تخوفها لبعدين وين راح نروح بس ان شاء
الله ما بصير غير خير استخدمت المعارضه
اللاجئين السوريين كورقه ضد الحكومه خلال
العقد الماضي من خلال تحميلهم مسؤوليه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه السيئه الانتقادات
تجاه اللاجئين تصاعدت بشكل كبير خلال
العامين الماضيين وقاد هذه الحمله على وجه
التحديد السياسي المتطرف المعادي للاجئين
اوميت اوز داغ
نعيدهم الى بلدهم والاشياء الاخرى لا تهمك
انت لست مواطنا تركيا سنعيدك الى بلدك
مرشح المعارضه للرئاسه كمالك الجدار اوغلو
تعهد مرارا باعاده اللاجئين اذا وصل
للرئاسه التخوفات موجوده السبب التخوفات
حقيقه صادره من وين صادرا من استخدام
الاحزاب في تركيا لهذه الورقه من اجل
الانتخابات دائما التوجه لورقه اللاجئين
واستخدامها بطرق واساليب تعتبر لانك سوري
مستفزه وتعتبر مخيفه نوعا ما لماذا نحن
الحلقه الاضعف في النهايه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان تعهد كذلك باعاده اللاجئين الى
مناطق امنه شمالي سوريا مراقبون ارجعوا
موقف اردوغان لتنامي حاله شعبيه تريد حل
مشكله اللاجئين واعادتهم وبالتالي اراد
الرئيس سحب هذه الورقه من معارضيه
وفق القانون الرئيسي هو من يقرر استقبال
موجات كبيره من مواطن دوله اخرى يتعرضون
للاضطهاد وفي ذات الوقت بقرار اداري من
الرئيس يمكن ان تتم اعادتهم لكن بشرط ضمان
شروط الحياه الانسانيه لهم في بلادهم
بالمحصله وكما في كل انتخابات تشهدها
البلاد حاله الخوف والقلق لدى اللاجئين
تبلغ اعلى مستوياتها قبل الانتخابات بايام
فحملات الوعيد والتهديد الصادره من
المنابر السياسيه تفوق بكثير بعض
التطمينات التي تاتي على خجل من هنا وهناك
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
من اسطنبول لا ينضم الى دكتور مهند حافظ
اوغلو الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي
الى اي حد ستنجح المعارضه باستخدام ورقه
اللاجئين لهزيمه اردوغان
ميسون وجميع المشاهدين فعلا هذه نقطه
لطالما لوحت بها المعارضه ولا تستخدمها
وكان تركيا وما فيها من مشكلات وما فيها
من ازمات وما فيها من مستقبل ينتظر شبابها
وينتظر تركيا كلها سينما ان هذه
الانتخابات تاتي متزامنه مع ذكرى المئويه
لقيام الجمهوريه التركيه الحديثه وكان كل
هذا لا تراه المعارضه وتنظر فقط الى ملف
فرعي ثانوي يؤثر بشكل محدود على الداخل
التركي يعني التخوف ليس فقط لدى اللاجئين
السوريين التخوف واضح وحقيقي وهذا ليس سرا
ان التخوف موجود لدى كل المرشحين ولد كل
الاحزاب ولد الشعب التركي
شمال سوريا هل يكون قد سحب هذه الورقه من
تحت بساط المعارضه
ليس بقدر انفتاح تركيا على دمشق برعايه
روسيه ومن ثم ايرانيه هذا التحرك
الدبلوماسي السياسي الذي نتج عن لقاء ما
بين وزراء الدفاع ومن ثم ينتظر بعد غد
لقاء على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه هذا الذي
ربما سحب الكرت كرت
الحوار مع دمشق والعداء مع النظام السوري
ومع سوريا كما تقود تصفها المعارضه هذا هو
الكرت الذي سحب من المعارضه ولكن التخوف
وهذا القلق وهذا التشنج الكبير الحاصل في
الداخل التركي وما هذه الاعداد الكبيره
سواء في لقاء امس الرئيس اردوغان وقبل وفي
يومه قبل اليوم كان لقاء كمالك مع ناخذه
هذه الاعداد المئويه الالاف 700 الف
تقريبا لكل هو مليون و700,000 او
1,800,000 للرئيس اردوغان هذا صحيح يدل
على دعم من ما ولكن هو ايضا على تخوف
حقيقي ما يميز هذه الانتخابات استاذه
ميسون انها تاتي في جوده ديمقراطي وواسع
لكل المرشحين ولكل الاحزاب
يتخوف اردوغان وحزبه من هذه الاعداد وهذه
الشباب التي ستصوت لاول مره وهي تقول
بانها ضد السلطاويه ضد الحزب الواحد ضد
الحزب الحاكم الواحد او الرئيس الذي يعني
يمسك بزمام الامور بكافه جوانبها وهذا
بالنسبه لهم لا يمثل الديمقراطيه في تركيا
الا يتخوف من هؤلاء الشباب
صحيح هو امتحان حقيقي وكبير لرئيس اردوغان
الذي يطمح الى ان يتمم اربع قرن في حكم
هذه البلاد في حيننا مرشح المعرضه يريد ان
يكسر التلك الحالات وتلك الاحباطات التي
تتوالى عليه في كل انتخابات ويقوم
بالخساره فيها وبالتالي الرئيس اردوغان
بالفعل يشهد انتخابات هي الاصعب التي تمر
عليه وذلك الاعتبارات عديده داخليه
وخارجيه وسيما انها تاتي بعيده زلزال كبير
وهذا له اثاره فضلا عن اولئك الشباب الذين
هم منقسمون قسم يريد ان يدعم المعارضه فقط
لاجل التغيير وان لا يبقى الرئيس اردوغان
هو الصوره الماثله امامهم واخرين سوف
يمتنعون عن التصويت اذ انهم لا يعلمون لا
يعلمون الى اين تذهب الامور واذا ما كانت
تصويتم قد يكون خاطئا قد يلومنا انفسهم
بالفعل انتهى وقت ولكن مزاعم الفساد التي
توجه للرئيس اردوغان التوربك حملته
الانتخابيه بايجاز لو سمحت
هذا الامر يعود للقضائي كانت هناك ادله
لدى المعارضه التي تتهم الرئيس اردوغان
وحزبه بهذا الفساد هل تقدمه للقضاء يعني
القضاء في تركيا مستقل وعندما تكون هناك
اي قضيه ايا كانت القضاء هو من يفصل فيها
وليس اساسا وليس الاحزاب شكرا لك من
اسطنبول دكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو الاكاديمي
والباحث السياسي على المشاركه معنا في
اخبار الساعه
يترقد سكان شمال غربي سوريا نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
والتاثيراتها على واقعهم خصوصا مع عوده
العلاقات بين النظام السوري ومحيطه ثلاث
بل ثلاثه سيناريوهات فانتظر سكان شمال
غربي سوريا تحددها نتائج الاستحقاق التركي
ومدى التزام المرشحين
بالتعهداتهم تابع
ساحه بوجه بعضها البعض في تركيا مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي وصفت بالطاحنه
جماهير غفيره لكل من اردوغان وكليتش دور
اوغلو اللذين حددا سياسيهما الداخليه
والخارجيه
يختلفان في ملفات داخليه ويلتقيان في اخرى
خارجيه ليبقى ملف الوجود التركي العسكري
والاداري شمال غربي سوريا مبهما وخائبا عن
الخطابات الانتخابيه معهد الشرق الاوسط
رسم في دراسه مستقبل شمال غربي سوريا على
ضوء الانتخابات في تركيا وثلاثه
سيناريوهات قائمه بحسب المعهد في
السيناريو الاول يفوز اردوغان بولايه
جديده ويتراجع فيها عن تصريحات اشارت الى
التطبيع مع دمشق ويبقي قواته شمال غربي
سوريا وتواصل ادارته ممارسه التاثير
الاكبر في المنطقه عبر الفصائل والهيئات
التي شكلتها وتدعمها فيما السيناريو
الثاني وبصرف النظر عن المرشح الرابع
تختار الاداره التركيه الانسحاب العسكري
الجزئي من شمال غربي سوريا وتبقي نفوذها
الاداري في المنطقه مع تقليص تدخلها في
الحكم اليومي للفصائل التي تدير المناطق
وتعيد العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع الاسد ولكن
تعيق السماح له ببسط سيطرته على المنطقه
وفي السيناريو الثالث يفوز كلتشدار اوغلو
ويلتزم بما تعهد به امام الناخبين
وبالتالي يبني جدارا فاصلا على طول الحدود
مع سوريا وينسحب الجيش التركي من شمال غرب
سوريا وتفك تركيا ارتباطها بفصائل ما يعرف
بالجيش الوطني السوري
تلك الحاله تصبح الفصائل المعارضه امام
خيارين هما اما الدخول في مواجهه مع الاسد
رغم فقدانها الدعم الاساسي او الدخول في
مصالحه معه بضمانه من وسيط كما حصل عندما
استعاد الدمشق السيطره على حلب ثلاثه
سيناريوهات اساسيه تنتظر شمال غربي سوريا
بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه انما
الثابت الوحيد هو رفض سكان تلك المنطقه
حتى اليوم العوده الى ما قبل 2011
[موسيقى]
وفي اخبار الساعه لدينا بعض لحظات في
اسعار النفط مع بدء انحسار مخاوف الركود
في امريكا
[موسيقى]
وفي ختام اخبار الساعه نذكر بابرز
العناوين
عشيه يوم النصر موسكو تحيي نصرا قديما
وعينها على اوكرانيا يتاهب
مع تجدد الاشتباكات وسط الخرطوم البرهان
يخشى ان تنتقل شراره الحرب الى ولايات
اخرى
[موسيقى]
مصادر استخباراتيه اردنيه تؤكد قتل
المطلوب الاول بتهريب المخدرات واستهداف
معمل للكبتاجون في درعا
السوريون في اجنده الانتخابات التركيه شبح
الترحيل يحوم مع اقتراب يوم الاقتراع
وننهي مشاهدينا اخبار الساعه لهذا اليوم
بما نشرته العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
للصور الرسميه لحفل تتويج الملك تشويلز
الثالث في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات